[Musica]
odissea nello spazio dallo spazio arriva
qualcosa arrivano dei virus tanti virus
che si diffondono su tutta la terra
cosa si fa si chiude si chiude tutto
perché si è capito che il virus passa da
uomo a uomo
si chiude tutto si chiudono porte
finestre case in strada non c'è nessuno
è come si mangia beh ci vorrebbe un
sistema per poter ordinare il cibo
online non c'è come ci si veste online
no no non c'è niente i ragazzi non vanno
a scuola le scuole sono chiuse come si
fa
ci vorrebbe la possibilità di fare
lezioni a distanza non c'è chi lo cura
il virus i farmaci farmaci antivirali
per esempio non ci sono gli anticorpi
monoclonali cosa sono gli anticorpi
monoclonali un vaccino sì un vaccino ma
ci vorrà tanto tempo succede davvero
2021 22 20 anni dopo non è proprio 2021
è un pochino prima ma è come se fosse
facciamo finta che sia vent'anni dopo il
virus arriva davvero si diffonde su
tutta la terra è un virus che a questi
spuntoni li chiamano spike e sotto
vedete in giallo e rosso
i recettori attraverso questa spike il
virus entra nelle nostre cellule
usa la spike come una chiave che apre la
serratura
il recettore viene dalla provincia di
hubei viene da wuhan di preciso dalla
cina
forse da questi mercati uniti dove gli
animali selvaggi sono uno sopra l'altro
con secrezioni escrementi e sporcizia li
vive il virus e poi da lì attraverso un
grande aeroporto internazionale
all'aereoporto di hubei si diffonde a
tutto il mondo
di colpo arriva in 23 paesi
arriva anche in italia si chiude tutto
si chiude tutto porte e finestre
nessuno per strada il virus passa da
uomo a uomo lo sappiamo di sicuro
e allora chiudiamo tutto abbiamo paura
non sappiamo cosa fare
però adesso nel 2021 c'è internet 1
ordinare da mangiare gli e lo portano a
casa può vestirsi
i ragazzi non vanno a scuola è un dramma
però vedono il maestro il professore
attraverso lo schermo del computer
possono leggere studiare nel computer
arrivano libri interagiscono con i
compagni coi professori
la gente sta male ci sono dei farmaci
dei farmaci antivirali
altri ricercatori stanno preparando
anticorpi monoclonali e chissà un
vaccino
il 10 gennaio il giorno in cui è stato
pubblicata la struttura del genoma del
virus il 10 gennaio il giorno in cui è
stata pubblicata la struttura del genoma
del virus
due ragazzi turchi che avevano messo in
piedi una piccola azienda in germania
incominciano a preparare un vaccino il
giorno stesso avevano delle conoscenze è
un vaccino a rna messaggero loro lo
avevano già preparato per le boe la non
c'erano arrivati ma avevano una
piattaforma pronta bayonne tech diventa
grande
da un piccolo laboratorio diventa un
grande building a in germania e la
germania si collega con new york bayonne
tech parla con i ricercatori fighter una
delle più grandi compagnie del mondo
diventa fighter bayonne tech e in 336
giorni fanno un vaccino un vaccino che
parte quando è stato scoperto il genoa
ma lo di giorno stesso
poi gli studi sugli animali poi la fase
1 alla fase due la fase iii alcune paesi
approvano il vaccino lo sottomettono
tutte le loro carte alle autorità
regolatorie la 11 dicembre erano partiti
il 10 gennaio del 2020 l'undici dicembre
prima che l'hanno finisse il primo
malato viene il primo la prima persona
viene vaccinata
con questo nuovo vaccino quanto ci
voleva fare un vaccino per una volta ci
volevano 110 anni e quello è quello che
è servito per farlo per la febbre
tifoide e verrà meningite ci sono voluti
80 e per la poliomielite 50 e poi solo
15 solo 15 per l'epatite b per le ball a
25 anni questo vaccino è stato fatto in
meno di un anno è un miracolo no non è
un miracolo ma è una cosa straordinaria
è una cosa straordinaria resa possibile
da tantissimi scienziati in tutto il
mondo che si sono messe lavorare insieme
vedete dai cerchi giallo arancione rosso
verde blu sono quelli che hanno lavorato
alla diagnosi a capire la malattia alle
strategie terapeutiche ai farmaci a
portare avanti dei prodotti innovativi
ai vaccini tutti insieme tutti i
ricercatori del mondo al di là di ogni
limite al di là di ogni limite e avere
un vaccino in 336 giorni
al di là di ogni limite precedente è
vedere tutti i ricercatori del mondo che
lavorano insieme
non è mai successo e adesso arrivano
alle autorità regolatorie 4 vaccini che
vengono approvati fighter bayonne tech
moderna astra zeneca johnson and johnson
efficacia per la malattia severa cento
per cento
questi bacini proteggono tutti dalla
malattia severa e dalla morte tutti e
quattro proteggono tutte le persone
e poi c'è un'aria efficacia variabile ma
molto alta per le piccole manifestazioni
della malattia
quattro approvati ne stanno arrivando 5
ma tutti quei ricercatori che avete
visto insieme ne stanno studiando 250
quello che vi ho fatto vedere prima era
nelle carte sottomessi alle autorità
regolatorie earth ea ema
ma cosa succede nel mondo cosa succede
alla gente che viene vaccinata succede
che diminuiscono i casi confermati di
covi 19 nelle persone che hanno più di
80 anni di giorno in giorno man mano che
si vaccina gennaio febbraio marzo marzo
marzo fine marzo finito
nessun paziente e con più di 80 anni si
ammala più in israele
e poi ci sono tutti gli altri alla fine
non si ammala più nessuno ma ma bisogna
andare oltre questo limite perché
arrivano alle varianti le varianti sono
quelle inglese che ormai ha sopraffatto
il virus originale in tutte le parti del
mondo poi una viene dalla california da
new york dal brasile della nigeria
dell'uganda dal sudafrica dall'india dal
giappone ma ma gli scienziati vanno
oltre quel limite lì lo sanno dove sono
le mutazioni le mutazioni sono vicino al
recettore alla chiave quella in cui la
spagna la serratura quella in cui la
chiave spy protein deve entrare fa
fatica perché lì ci sono delle mutazioni
le mutazioni certe volte facilitano
l'entrata della chiave e allora diventa
contagiosissima come quello inglese
la malattia vedete però che altre
mutazioni sono coperte da un anticorpo
allora siamo andati oltre ogni limite
gli scienziati hanno trovato degli
anticorpi contro le mutazioni e dopo due
settimane di vaccinazione con la
variante inglese c'è un certo effetto
13 per cento 33 per cento passano
quattro settimane 80 per cento sei
settimane secondo vaccinazione 92 per
cento anche contro le varianti e poi con
questi vaccini mrna qualunque variante
può essere combattuta con un nuovo
vaccino che ha bisogno di sei settimane
ma sei settimane potrebbero essere tante
e allora c'è un nna messaggero polici
straw nico cosa vuol dire
si parte dal dna il dna forma un nr ana
messaggero quello che porta il messaggio
per formare la proteina ma questa volta
questo messaggero è polici straw nico
cioè forma tante proteine allo stesso
tempo così il virus non sa più come fare
a evadere tutte queste proteine che lo
circondano da tutte le parti ci vuole
tanto però a fare questi vaccini
bisognerebbe andare oltre a questo
limite
e allora ci vuole tanto perché ci
vogliono questi bioreattori ci vuole la
catena del freddo mrna è molto fragile e
allora agli scienziati inseriscono una
sequenza genetica in un batterio che
vive nella terra nella terra dove si
coltivano delle pianticelle che
assomigliano a quelle del tabacco le
piante prendono quel batterio e
cominciano a produrre la proteina una
proteina che può essere usato come un
vaccino se il virus comincia a mutare
allora loro possono cambiare la
produzione di quel vaccino usando
semplicemente delle nuove piante 12.500
metri quadri che cos'è è la superficie
che basta per coltivare abbastanza
piante per creare abbastanza vaccino per
tutti quelli che avranno bisogno di
vaccino nel nostro paese quasi 60
milioni di italiani
ma la ricerca e così internazionale
avete visto tutti quei ricercatori
lavorare insieme nel messico ci sono dei
ricercatori fantastici che lavorano
sulle piante sui pomodori pomodori che
mangiamo noi vengono dall'america latina
c'è una grande tradizione
ecco questi stanno creando questi
ricercatori dei pomodori che si possono
mangiare e che contengano
linee che combattono il virus quindi il
vaccino di un altro limite ancora sarà
quello del pomodoro modificato
geneticamente per produrre il vaccino ma
ma non è tutto così semplice perché
questo uomo shengli ha identificato
decine di sars coflight virus virus che
assomigliano quelli del sas che sono
letali in queste cave dove vivono i
pipistrelli
lasciate stare i pipistrelli diceva un
filosofo cinese
lui pensa a questo uomo che in quelle
cave non ci siano soltanto decine di
questi virus come sasco ce ne sono
probabilmente molto di più e tutti sono
altrettanto pericolosi come facciamo
questo è un limite che non riusciamo a
superare direte voi no superiamo anche
questo limite ci sono dei vaccini che
sono fatti in questo modo si mette in
mezzo una nano medicina e tutte quelle
protrusioni che vedete fuori rossa
gialla verde sono delle spike protesi
che stanno appiccicati alla stessa
piccola nanomedicina così piccola che si
chiama nanomedicina una misura
piccolissima e questa la vedete in nero
come il carbone
lì ci sono intorno tutte le spy rothen
di tutti i possibili coronavirus di
tutti quei pipistrelli che avete visto
dai ricercatori l'hanno presentato uno
studio perché fosse allen a jesi perché
potesse essere finanziato dicevano
questa è una cosa molto importante sarà
una cosa molto importante e chi ha
rivisto questa applicazione questi altri
ricercatori del national institute of
health che somiglia al nostro istituto
superiore sanità hanno detto fantastico
però i soldi non me li possiamo dare
perché insomma non siamo convinti che
serva poi che sia così necessario non ci
sarà mai un virus che porrà un problema
globale a tutta la terra si sbagliavano
come si sbagliano quelli che pensano che
la terra sia per noi
noi abbiamo sempre pensato io ho sempre
pensato che la terra fosse per l'uomo
molti di voi avranno sempre pensato che
la terra fosse per noi la terra non è
per noi la terra è di tutti e queste
cose queste pandemie questo problema
globale viene perché noi eravamo
convinti che la terra fosse per noi
quindi non abbiamo fatto attenzione agli
animali ai pesci ai vermi ai molluschi a
quelli che volano alle piante a tutte le
creature che vivono nel mondo la mia
vita dipende da ciascuna di queste
creature la nostra vita dipende dai
batteri che abbiamo nell'intestino ci
sono miliardi di batteri nel nostro
intestino che contribuiscono al nostro
genoma più di quanto non contribuiscano
rna il dna delle nostre cellule
allora la mia vita dipende dalla tua la
tua dipende da quella di una creatura
molto piccola
la libertà che noi valutiamo così tanto
è la libertà degli altri la libertà di
avere nei mari delle piccole pesci che
possano rendere il mare capace di essere
un ambiente ospitale per tutti gli altri
perché senza il mare senza tutte le
piante senza gli animali senza che i
pipistrelli stiano in pace nelle loro
case sono preziosissimi perché sennò
saremmo piedi di zanzare in tutto il
mondo non possiamo più dire che la
politica del mio paese è la mia priorità
il sovrani smo è morto è però stanno
morendo le api e se noi non abbiamo
abbastanza ap non avremo abbastanza
agricoltura senza abbastanza agricoltura
non avremmo fiori frutti piante e
soprattutto non avremo da mangiare per
tutta la popolazione del mondo grazie